stunning Victory an amazing uppercut
knockout and I'm delighted to say Tyson
Fury joins me live from his home in
Morecambe in Lancashire welcome to you
champ how are you
I'm good thanks Pierce congratulations
on being back on TV I didn't come here
for long today he's back he's back baby
you know what Tyson it reminds me of the
Old Rocky Balboa clothes not how many
times you get hit down it's how many
times you get back on your feet and keep
going forward right
100 percent
you've got to keep moving forward in a
positive manner and never let anybody
anybody tell you you can't do something
because there's so many dream Crushers
out there and naysayers and they all
want you to see you on the floor but
you've got to keep getting back up and
disappointing numbers that's what you
keep doing when you heard Tyson Sharon
Osborne telling her story could you
believe really what happened to her what
do you make of this canceled culture
with having an opinion or even saying
someone's allowed opinion you get your
life ruined and you get fired
I think the world has gone my dear pear
she can't there's only a freedom of
speech until it upsets somebody and it
doesn't exist anymore
um and like you said in the interview
this is what you guys get paid to do of
your opinion so if your opinion's no
good then what's the point you know it's
it's one of them it's uh the world's
gone crazy and it's a shame that people
like yourself unlike Sharon and even me
we can't say stuff we're going to offend
this person that person you gotta watch
your p's and q's for everything because
even wearing this blue t-shirt I'm
offending somebody yeah could be a
complaint for sure I was about to say I
find it really offensive that's mainly
because I'm an Arsenal fan
yeah exactly and and all my United fans
will find it offensive Tim so I said let
me talk to you quickly about uh the
fight please everybody Pierce I don't
want to please everybody I don't know
about you I don't want to please
everybody I just want to have my honest
opinions that other people have theirs
have a good argument and go and have a
beer what happened to that that used to
be how our democracy and Society worked
well things change when I was in 2022
and everything you say gets uh taken
personal and um everyone wants to cancel
you out you know for everything you say
so you just gotta watch what you're
saying piss check him out and that's not
very good when you're around
you know what I'm not going to watch
what I say Tyson because I don't think
you do either really I think that both
of us I think have the self-confidence
to say you know what stuff this nonsense
uh yeah stuff the fun police is saying
what my great friend used to say uh
because I think it's just so what it
does it removes all the fun out of life
it makes life a very joyless kind of
experience doesn't it
it does when you can't can't speak the
truth and you think what you think it's
um it's become crazy I don't know what's
going on in the world everybody's upset
for something and no matter what you say
can please everybody but for me the only
person I'm interested in pleasing is my
wife and I'm struggling with that most
of the time
he moment Tyson at the end of your fight
when you claimed you're going to retire
everybody was groaning nobody wanted to
hear that and your wife looked to me
like she was saying no he's not
something like that she certainly gave
an indication that she doesn't think
you're ready to retire yet why would you
retire you walked out in front of nearly
a hundred thousand people at Wembley
going crazy you're at the peak of your
powers you knock out this guy with a
ruthless uppercut there are still one or
two massive fights left for you the
winner of the Joshua uzik fight
obviously would be a huge one I don't
think you're ready to retire Tyson Fury
give me the scoop are you gonna now tell
me right now here's Morgan uncensored
that actually you've got more in you
well let me tell you something Pierce
Morgan uncensored this is the truth the
gospel truth nothing but the truth I'm
done you know every good dog has its day
and like the great Roman leader said
there'll always be somebody else to
fight when is enough and off I'm happy
I'm healthy I've still got my brains I
can still talk I've got a beautiful wife
I've got six kids I've got obtained
belts I've got plenty of money success
Fame Glory what what more am I doing it
for you know boxing's a very dangerous
sport you can be taken out with one
punch as we've seen on Saturday night
and you know it only takes one lucky
blow one a lucky blow and you may not
get up off that canvas I'm quitting
while I'm ahead I'm undefeated under the
second man in history to retire
undefeated heavyweight champion I'm very
very happy and very contented in the
heart with what I've done what I've
achieved it's not about money for me
Pierce you know a lot of people in this
world everything's about money and more
money and more money I've got enough
money I've got enough of everything I
need I'm a very simple man I drive an 07
VW Passat
I'm a very normal person I don't need
tons of money to to impress everybody do
you know what I think
honestly that I've ever interviewed I
think the way your mind works I think
you're quite a complex thinker you're a
deep thinker you're highly intelligent
and yet you do this you know incredibly
violent sport but that's why in a way I
do believe you because I do think you've
probably calculated you look at the
greats Muhammad Ali who go on too long
who do one big fight too many who get
battered and then never recover I can
understand it I can understand why you
may have with your smart mind calculated
it's just not worth it
it's not worth it you know I've got
family to raise I've got kids to I've
got four young kids to raise and two bit
older ones
um I've been away for the last 10 years
on the road all over the world traveling
for boxing you know when do I get time
to be a father a husband a brother or
son I need this personal time you know
the fans will always want more they
always paying for more blood but at the
end of the day I don't have anything
more to give I've give everything I've
got I've been a professional 14 years
and I've been boxing over 20 years I'm
all every good dog has to stay in the
Sun and my time is to go out on a high
and I always said that I wanted to walk
away on top of the sport
um do it on my terms and I didn't want
to be the person who said well I should
have maybe retired two years ago or
whatever I just wanted to walk out on
top go out with a bang nearly a hundred
thousand at Wembley with a knockout
performance they will not forget the
Gypsy King in a hurry and for sure and
no amount of of material assets or money
will make make me come back out of
retirement because I'm very happy I
completely you know what Tyson I
completely respect you and I get your
argument for it I wanted to ask you a
question uh when I did Celebrity
Apprentice with Donald Trump and I might
ask you a question about Donald Trump in
a moment because I know you know him but
when I did it uh with Donald Trump
Lennox Lewis was in there with me and
Lennox told me when he was the World
Heavyweight Champion everywhere he used
to go in America in particular you go to
a bar or a club and the biggest guy in
the bar in the club would want to come
and take him on to prove their point do
you get that and he said he used to take
them on very quickly and I said what
happened to them he went I was a
heavyweight champion of the world what
do you think happened to him do you get
that when you go into pubs and things to
people say oh come on then Tyson me and
you
you know what Pierce never I've not got
that Persona or aura about me where I
don't think I'm a tough guy I don't walk
around like the big man
um I don't think I've ever been
approached in a bar or a pub coming from
a former alcoholic don't forget I used
to go to a lot of bars and pubs and
restaurants
um I've never been in a fight outside
the ring in my whole life I've not got
that um Persona of like oh come and take
me on I'm more like a happy-go-lucky
type when you saw when you saw the other
types when you saw the other Tyson from
your sport Mike Tyson having that
incident on a plane where some guy was
drunk and goading him and eventually
Tyson gave him a bit of a slap what did
you make of that
well you know Mike Tyson's a real OG and
you can't master a mic because you just
don't know what he's going to do but all
the people all the fun police like you
just said before they'll all be on Mike
to get him canceled as well
um but how can you go around prodding a
lion with a stick how long can you prod
a guy for before he does something about
it you know Mike's Mike Mike don't get
the name for the baddest man on the
planet for nothing so he's not the guy
you want a problem for step on the back
of a plane until you get chinned and
that's exactly what happened to the guy
and then he wants to cry about it
if he's smart enough to prod Mike Tyson
and touch him and call him names and
abuse him on a plane then man up and
take a punch in the face so what you
should be paying Mike now you can say
you've been punching the face by a
legend and a world heavyweight champion
Mike Tyson Tyson if you're not going to
be boxing I'd pay for that myself
if you're not going to be boxing anymore
Tyson what's what's your big ambition
what's your big what's your big game in
life now
my big aim in life now passes to get a
job next to you interviewing people and
and talking my mind get off
and very quickly I'm told you had a chat
with Donald Trump recently where he said
to you he is going to run again for
president is that true
well I think he'll be running again for
president 100 why not why not
but he told you that last time he told
you that I think he'll get it I think
he'll I think yeah I I think he'll get
it this time for sure
2024 I think Donald Trump will be
president of the United States again
thank you